das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich. Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir.
Ja, natürlich. Bevor Ihre Beschwerden anfangen, muss ich Ihren persönlichen Daten fragen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Irma Müller.
Bitte können Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ja, das ist beides, kurz und einfach.
Ihr Vorname ist Irma und Ihr Familienname ist Müller.
M-U-umlaut, also Ü-doppel-L-E-R.
Frau Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 37.
Okay. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 13.06.89.
13.06.89.
Aber es ist falsch, ich glaube.
Wieso?
11 plus 26 ist 37.
37, ja, ich habe gehört siebenund.
Ja, aber sind wir als Sie wieder?
Ich bin 37 Jahre alt.
37, ja.
Und wir haben jetzt das Jahr 19... äh, 2026.
Okay, ja klar.
Und von 89 bis zu null ist...
Ja, 89, 89, okay.
Jahrgang 89, genau.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 Meter.
1,68 Meter. Und wie viel sind Sie wiegen?
Äh, ich wiege 69 Kilo.
69 Kilo, okay.
Frau Müller, was fühlt Sie heute zu uns?
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, eigentlich was ganz Banales.
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Und zwar Bauchschmerzen, die haben...
Ja, die haben gestern angefangen eigentlich.
Und da war das so... ja, so mitten im Bauch, so im Magen.
Und dann habe ich mich aber zunehmend schlechter gefühlt.
Ich hatte auch das Gefühl, die Schmerzen werden immer mehr.
Und dann musste ich mich einmal übergeben.
Und dann hatte ich auch das Gefühl, dass ich Fieber habe.
Und ich habe tatsächlich ein bisschen Temperatur.
Und ja, und jetzt sind die Schmerzen so runtergewandert in den rechten Unterbauch.
Und da habe ich jetzt auch, Mensch, jetzt aber mal...
Und es krampft und sticht und ist richtig...
Ich habe heftige Schmerzen jetzt.
Ja, es tut mir leid, dass Sie solche stärken Schmerzen haben.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen von einer Schmerzskala 0 bis 10?
0 ist kein Schmerzen, 10 ist der stärkste Schmerzen.
Oh, das sind schon heftige Schmerzen.
Also ich... sagen wir mal, ja, heftigste 6 bis 7 würde ich vielleicht so sagen.
Okay.
Und wie... könnten Sie bis am Ende dieses Gespräch, diese Schmerzen aushalten, oder...?
Ja, ich habe das ja jetzt schon den ganzen Tag eigentlich.
Insofern, es kommt auf ein paar Minuten auch nicht an.
Okay.
Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Na, das ging ziemlich plötzlich los.
Plötzlich.
Und zwar, eigentlich fing das gestern an so nach dem Abendessen.
Da hatte ich das schon.
Und dann dachte ich halt, ja, irgendwie ein bisschen was Verkehrtes gegessen oder was weiß ich.
Aber das habe ich noch nicht so ernst genommen.
Aber als mir dann so schlecht wurde und ich mich übergeben musste und die Schmerzen dann immer schlimmer wurden,
dann habe ich gedacht, na jetzt musst du dich doch mal kümmern.
Okay. Fühlen Sie sich jetzt auch übel?
Nee, im Augenblick geht es gerade.
Ah, okay.
Und sind die Schmerzen dauerhafter oder gehen Sie wieder weg sind?
Nee, ganz weggegangen sind die nicht.
Ich habe also entsprechend auch in der Nacht nicht gut geschlafen.
Und was so ein bisschen was gebracht hat,
also beim Liegen im Bett fand ich es eigentlich gar nicht so angenehm.
Aber ich habe mich dann so zusammengekauert.
Dann hatte ich das Gefühl, so die Knie angezogen und auf der Seite gelegen,
da hatte ich das Gefühl, es war ein klein wenig besser.
Ja, ich verstehe das.
Könnten Sie mir bitte diese Schmerzen erklären?
Wie sind diese Schmerzen?
Dumpfes, Stechens, Zehens?
Also erst einmal habe ich so das Gefühl, dass es zusammenkramft und es sticht, würde ich sagen, am ehesten.
So erst krammfertige, aber momentan fühlen Sie sich stechend.
Ja, beides.
Gibt es jemanden, der in ihrer Umgebung auch ähnliche Beschwerde hat?
Weil haben Sie schon gesagt, nach dem Abendessen plötzlich aufgesprungen.
Nee, ich bin die einzige, die die Probleme hat.
Die anderen haben alle nichts.
Okay.
Gibt es ein paar versteckte Faktoren für diese Schmerzen?
Ja, wie gesagt, wenn ich mich hingelegt habe, da hatte ich ja gedacht, es würde besser werden,
aber es war eher schlechter.
Ja.
Und angefangen hat es eben nach dem Essen.
Ja, also ich habe dann auch heute Morgen so ein Weißbrot gegessen und ein bisschen Tee getrunken.
Aber ich hatte auch keinen Appetit, ehrlich gesagt.
Ah, okay.
Ich verstehe, dass das so wichtige Informationen für uns sind.
Und Frau Müller, ist das erst einmal für Sie oder haben Sie schon ähnliche Beschwerde früher?
Natürlich habe ich in meinem Leben schon Bauchschmerzen gehabt, ja klar.
Aber jetzt, dass das so heftig ist und auch so, dass ich mich so krank fühle.
Das habe ich noch nicht gehabt, das ist das erste Mal.
Okay.
Frau Müller, schreien diese Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Nee, also die sind jetzt halt so im rechten Unterbauch.
Da sind sie untergebracht, ja, aber sie strahlen nicht aus.
Okay, okay.
Frau Müller, haben Sie schon gesagt, leiden Sie unter Fieber?
Haben Sie schon gemessen?
Ja, ich habe gemessen. Das war 38.1 gestern Abend.
38.1 Celsius. Wo haben Sie das gemessen?
Ich habe so einen Stirnthermometer.
Okay. Noch einmal haben Sie erbrochen?
Ja, genau. Ja, Gott sei Dank nicht ständig, ja. Ich finde das sehr unangenehm.
Aber ich habe jetzt auch nicht mehr viel gegessen, wie gesagt.
Ja, ja, das ich verstehe.
Und Frau Müller, leiden Sie unter auch Katschweiß, Nachtschweiß, Müdigkeit?
Nee, sowas habe ich nicht.
Okay. Und haben Sie Brustschmerzen, Luftnot, Engelgefühl, Halsrasen?
Nein, ich habe nur Bauchschmerzen. Also hier oben habe ich nichts, nee.
Okay. Und leiden Sie unter auch Blechungen, Sauerausstoss, Sodbrennen?
Sauerausstoss? Nee, da habe ich eigentlich normal keine Probleme mit, nee.
Und Blechungen, das habe ich schon hin und wieder mal, aber nicht besonders.
Haben Sie auch Völlegefühl?
Was habe ich?
Völlegefühl.
Nee, das ist ja was anderes. Mir war so schlecht und ich habe so keinen Appetit, aber Völlegefühl nennen würde ich das nicht nennen, nee.
Okay, okay. Seit gestern Abend haben Sie erfettet Lausigkeit?
Ja, also zum Abend habe ich eigentlich ja noch gegessen. Und als es dann danach anfing,
da hatte ich dann das Gefühl, ich habe bloß nichts mehr essen, ja.
Okay. Und ich würde gerne wissen, wann war Ihre letzte Monatsblutzung?
Ja, das ist, lassen Sie mich überlegen, das ist drei Wochen her.
Okay, vor drei Wochen. Und sind Sie Ihre Frauenarzt regelmäßig besucht?
Ich besuche meine Frauenarzt regelmäßig, ja, also einmal im Jahr halt. Und da war alles normal.
Ich nehme halt zur Verhütung die Pille. Insofern habe ich eben auch einen regelmäßigen Zyklus.
Stimmt, wichtig, dass Sie das sagen. Ich muss natürlich jetzt aufpassen, weil ich mich einmal übergeben hatte.
Ja, natürlich. Aber ich werde alle Wahrscheinliche überprüfen, machen Sie keine Sorgen.
Frau Müller, haben Sie Stuhlgang oder Wasserlässeprobleme?
Beispielsweise Durchfall, Verstopfung, Blut oder Schleim im Stuhl?
Nee, also am Stuhl ist mir tatsächlich noch nichts aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Wasserlässeprobleme?
Nein, also um Gottes Willen, ich bin 37 Jahre alt, da habe ich hoffentlich keine Probleme damit. Nee, habe ich nicht.
Okay, ja klar, super. Und Frau Müller, möchten Sie noch etwas, irgendwelche Beschwerde zeigen?
Nee, ich habe Ihnen das glaube ich so gut beschrieben, wie ich konnte.
Okay, und Frau Müller, leiden Sie an irgendwelchen Erkrankungen?
Ja, also tatsächlich habe ich eine Siltdruckungunterfunktion und muss deswegen regelmäßig Medikamente nehmen.
Alteryxin oder ansonsten?
Genau, und damit ist es eigentlich ganz gut eingestellt.
Okay, wie viele Mikroprogramme nehmen Sie?
Oh, was steht da drauf? Ich kann es Ihnen aus dem Kopf nicht sagen.
Die Packung liegt ja immer auf meinem Tisch, aber ich könnte Ihnen aus dem Kopf jetzt nicht sagen, was für eine Dosierung drauf steht.
Okay, okay.
Aber das ist immer die gleiche, also das ist vom Hausarzt eingestellt.
Okay, ich kann einmal Kontakt mit Hausarzt bleiben.
Ja, die können Ihnen das bestimmt sagen. Das kann ich auch meinem Mann fragen. Das liegt ja zu Hause auf dem Tisch.
Er kann ja nachgucken, was da drauf steht.
Ja, ist das so hilfreich, sind Sie so nett. Danke schön.
Frau Müller, ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie einmal operiert wurden?
Nee, als Kind habe ich die Mandeln rausbekommen, ja.
War diese Operation komplikationslos?
Ja, da war ich ja noch klein, das war ja auch nur ein kleiner Eingriff. Das ist damals ambulant gemacht worden.
Nee, das hat keine Probleme gegeben.
Okay, und wissen Sie schon, mit welchem Lebensjahr? 10, 12, 8?
Wie alt ich war? Das weiß ich ziemlich genau. Ich war 10 Jahre alt.
10 Jahre alt, okay.
Frau Müller, haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich irgendwas habe, worauf ich allergisch reagiere. Das muss ich wirklich nachdenken.
Also ich meine, ich kann alles essen. Ich mag nicht alles, aber ich vertrage eigentlich glaube ich alles.
Okay.
Frau Müller, sind Sie Raucherin?
Das habe ich zum Glück nie angefangen. Das spart mir eine Menge Geld.
Okay, ich gratuliere Ihnen, das ist so eine gute Entscheidung für Ihre Gesundheit.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke hin und wieder mein Glas Wein, ja. Das trinke ich ausgesprochen gerne.
Und ja, wenn es ein gutes Essen gibt oder wenn es was zu feiern gibt, trinke ich schon sehr gerne mein Glas Wein.
Gelegentlich meinen Sie, ja?
Ja, also nicht Tag für Tag und nicht schon morgens oder so.
Okay, ich verstehe. Und Frau Müller, konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Ich? Nee, nee, das habe ich auch nie gemacht.
Super. Das ist nur eine flüchtliche Frage, weil Drogen hat so viele Nebenwirkungen oder mit anderen Medikamenten Wechselwirkungen.
Deshalb musste ich diese Frage stellen.
Frau Müller, könnten Sie mir bitte zeigen, ob Ihre Eltern gesund sind?
Meine Eltern? Also mein Vater hatte, der war dann noch nicht so alt.
Da hatte der mal einen Herzinfarkt und hat daraufhin dann so einen kleinen Eindruck bekommen.
Da hat er sich aber sehr gut erholt. Der hat einmal so einen Stent bekommen oder mehrere Stents sogar.
Und war dann danach in der Reha und der hatte sich aber richtig gut erholt.
Okay, ich verstehe das. Und haben Sie schon erinnern, wie alt der Vater an den Herzinfarkt war?
Wie alt er war, als er den Herzinfarkt hatte?
Ja. Uh, da war er so 67 oder so.
67. Okay.
Das ist noch gar nicht so furchtbar lange her.
Und leiden Ihre Mutter an irgendwelchen Erkrankungen?
Nein, meine Mutter ist erschreckend gesund. Also die hat bisher nichts.
Okay. Sie ist auch ein paar Jahre junger als mein Vater.
Ich verstehe das. Frau Müller, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe zwei Schwestern.
Sind sie gesund?
Nein, die eine ist tatsächlich ein bisschen älter als ich. Die hat eine Brustkrebserkrankung.
Und ist behandelt und operiert und hat es eigentlich jetzt ganz gut, soweit man das sagen kann, hinter sich gebracht.
Okay, super.
Und die zweite Schwester?
Die zweite Schwester ist total gesund, ja.
Frau Müller, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind auch ziemlich klein. Wir haben zwei Kinder.
Zwei Kinder, okay. Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder? Ja, überwiegend. Hin und wieder schleppen sie irgendwas aus der Kita an. Aber grundsätzlich haben wir keine schlimmen Erkrankungen.
Haben Sie schon gesagt, beim Abendessen war ich alleine? Normalerweise haben Sie alleine gelebt?
Nein, ich war nicht alleine. Ich bin die Einzige, die die Schmerzen hat.
Die anderen haben keine Beschwerden. Wir haben das Gleiche gegessen. Und die anderen haben keine Beschwerden.
Okay, danke schön. Was machen Sie beruflich, Frau Müller?
Ich arbeite Teilzeit bei einer Versicherung.
Teilzeit arbeiten Sie? Ja, wegen der Kinder halt.
Okay, ja, natürlich.
Frau Müller, sind Sie vollgeimpft?
Meinen Sie gegen Corona?
Nein, natürlich.
Ja, Covid bin ich natürlich seinerzeit geimpft worden. Aber das ist jetzt auch schon wieder ziemlich lange her.
Und ansonsten, ja, was weiß ich, ich bin mal hingefallen und hatte irgendwann eine Wunde im Garten.
Und dann habe ich eine Tetanus-Impfung bekommen. Also das ist noch nicht so lange her.
Aber sonst die Kinderimpfung, ja, das habe ich natürlich alles bekommen.
Okay, ja. Frau Müller, ich bin nun meine Fragen fertig. Vielen Dank für Ihre Offenheit und Ihre Geduld.
Laut Ihrer Beschwerden verdachte ich auch eine Belinddarmentzündung.
Oh ja, das kann natürlich sein. Ja, das habe ich bisher nicht gehabt.
Das bleibt nur eine Vermutung. Deshalb müssen wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Zuerst möchte ich Ihnen körperliche Untersuchungen vornehmen, Blut für das Labor abnehmen und auch EKG schreiben und Herzlische Ursachen schließen.
Und auch natürlich Bauchultraschall durchführen, auch Schutur überprüfen, Ihre Schutur überprüfen.
Hoffentlich kann ich da was bieten. Ja.
Nachdem Ihre Befunde vorliegen, bespreche ich mit meinem Opferarzt und ich komme Ihnen zurück und ich erkläre Ihnen alles, wie es weitergeht.
Ja, da bin ich aber sehr gespannt. Okay, gut.
Haben Sie andere Fragen oder möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, das haben Sie mir jetzt erklärt, wie es weitergeht.
Dann warte ich hier auf Sie, bis es weitergeht mit der Untersuchung und dann rufe ich vielleicht mal zu Hause an und sage, dass es hier noch ein bisschen dauert.
Ja, natürlich. Okay, gut. Danke schön. Bis gleich. Tschüss.
Frau Mülös, darf ich eine Frage stellen? Natürlich.
Haben Sie Schmerzen beim Erschütterung? Ich meinte, das beim Nissen, beim Husten.
Ich musste jetzt nicht husten, aber als mein Mann mich hierher gebracht hat, beim Autofahren, da hatte ich schon das Gefühl, wenn das so ein bisschen gehuckelt hat, hat es ein bisschen weh. Ja.
Okay, vielen Dank. Ja, es bleiben nicht viele Fragen. Sie hat sehr erschöpfend gefragt.
Danke schön. Ich glaube, es sind nicht viele Themen, die nicht angeschnitten sind. Möchte noch jemand was fragen?
Was haben Sie gegessen? Möglicherweise verdobene Essen oder? Nee, ich habe das Gleiche gegessen wie die Familie.
Selbstgekocht oder im Restaurant? Nee, selbstgekocht zu Hause, natürlich. Zu Hause, ja.
Nudelauflauf und Salat hatten wir. Wir haben alle das Gleiche gegessen, aber die anderen hatten keine Beschwerden.
Frau Müller, haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ab- oder Zugehung?
Nö. Also mein Gewicht ist eigentlich seit die Kinder da sind, ist das stabil.
Hat jemand noch Fragen? Möchten Sie das so gleich weitermachen, Frau Doktor?
Ja, natürlich. Sie sieht schon ganz erwartungsfreudig aus.
Ja, nicht so klar, natürlich, aber... Schauen wir mal.
Okay. Hallo, guten Tag, Frau Oberärztin. Mein Name ist Fatima Kübra-Ayildiz.
Ich habe heute neue Patienten aufgenommen. Es geht um Irma Müller.
Frau Müller ist 37-jährige Patientin, geboren am 30.06.1989.
Sie ist 1,88 Meter groß sowie 69 Kilo schwer.
Sie stellt sich seit gestern bestehende progrediente Bauchschmerzen im Unterbauch vor.
Laut Angaben der Patienten sind die Schmerzen plötzlich post-parandial aufgetreten.
Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen stechen und sichern momentan, aber auch krampfartig.
Die Schmerzinterzettel liegt bei 7, 8 von 10 auf der NRS.
Nach Angaben der Patienten sind die Schmerzen ausgewandert von peri- und kailen Bereich zu rechter Unterbau.
Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen nicht ausstrahlen.
Als verhinderte Faktoren berichtet sie für die Zustellungsposition.
Als verstärkende Faktoren berichtet sie auch für das Essen.
Sie klagt über Fiebererbrechen, Übelkeit und als vegetative Anamnistisch ergaben sich innerpartens- und insomniaschmerzbedingte.
Die genakologische Anamnistik war unaufällig.
Sie blutete vor drei Wochen und nahm eine Pille für die Verhütung.
Als Vorerkrankungenanamnese erwähnte sie lediglich Hypothrose.
Als Medikamenteanamnese erwähnte sie Einnahme von Eltroxin und Claredosis.
Als Operationanamnese ergab sich lediglich Transdilektomie mit Säntelebensia.
Diese Operation war komplikationslos.
Allergieanamnese war nicht bekannt.
Bei der Nuxanamnese erwähnte sie lediglich einen gelegentlichen Alkoholkonsum.
Ein Glas Wein pro Woche oder mit Ferien.
Als familielle Anamnese ergaben sie beim Vater ein Herzinfarkt, aber momentan ist er stabil.
Die Mutter ist gesund, aber ihre Schwester leidet an Brustkrebs, aber ist momentan stabil.
Also sie ist behandelt?
Als soziale Anamnese ist sie verheiratet, hat zwei Kinder und lebt mit ihren Familien.
Sie arbeitet im Versicherungsbereich.
Die anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf akutes Appendicitis hin.
Was könnte es differenzial diagnostisch sein?
Als differenzial diagnostisch kommen Urolithiasis oder Overtorsion in Betracht.
Und machen Sie diagnostisch?
Ja, um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich körperliche Untersuchungen vornehmen.
Witterparameter überwachen, EKG schreiben, um herzliche Ursachen auszuschließen.
Um was für eine Ursache auszuschließen?
Herzliche Ursachen auszuschließen.
Okay, weiter?
Natürlich Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Im Labor würde ich gerne Blutbild, Ernst und Paramez, Nierenwärze, Leberwärze, Betahelze, G-Kolestaswärze bestimmen lassen.
Und auch ich werde Stuhl- und Urindiagnostik machen.
Anschließend werde ich Sonoabdome und auch Möktgenabdome verwenden lassen.
Ja, was erwarten Sie beim Sonoabdome?
Ich erwarte vergrößerte Appendicitis und Verdickung der Wände und auch korrete Zeichnen, Tagzeichen.
Okay, ja.
Ja, ich erwarte das beim Sonoabdome.
Und bei der rein körperlichen Untersuchung, was wäre das Naheliegende überhaupt?
Ja, es gibt ein paar spezifische Untersuchungen für Appendicitis.
Beispielweise Losachszeichen, Psoaszeichen und McBurnay-Zeichen.
Und auch kollaterale Zeichen.
Ja.
Kollaterale? Waren Sie nicht? Ja, okay, wie auch immer. Sie kennen mehr als ich.
Ja, wenn sich das bestätigt, dass die eine akute Appendicitis hat, was ist dann die Therapie?
Ja, natürlich würde ich diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen und Flüssigkeit und Elektrolistik zuvor.
Und Nahrung, Karenz ist erforderlich sein und auch Analgetika, Antiemetika und Antibiotika anordnen.
Und natürlich chirurgisches und gastroenterologisches Konzept anzulocken.
Gut, ja, okay, dann bin ich gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt, ob sich das bestätigt mit der Appendicitis oder halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über Ihre Ergebnisse?
Ja.
Und ja, das war natürlich eine sehr schöne Anamnese.
Danke schön.
Und auch eine sehr vollständige Darstellung der Ergebnisse.
Ich bin gar nicht so schnell mitgekommen, weil ich zwischendurch mal was aufschreiben wollte und dann verliert man ganz schnell den Schaden.
Aber ich denke mal, Sie haben sehr, sehr vollständig wiedergegeben, was Sie alles die Patientin gefragt haben.
Ja, Sie machen inhaltlich ganz wenig Fehler oder so gut wie keine, wo ich nicht so sicher bin bei den Zahlen.
Ich meine, wir haben gesagt 30.6.
Ja, jetzt 30.6.
Und Sie haben gesagt 310.6.
Ja, das ist natürlich nicht die Lösung.
Ich kann nicht gut aussprechen, aber ich schreibe hier 30.
Ja, nicht 13.
Schreibe ich.
Gut, dann habe ich vielleicht auch nicht so deutlich gesprochen, aber da muss man halt nachfragen.
Also 310.6.
1989.
Ja.
Und ja, also das vielleicht noch ein kleines bisschen üben.
Und Sie sagen genau das, was eigentlich mal die größte Schwierigkeit bei Ihnen ist.
Das ist Ihre Aussprache.
Man versteht Sie.
Man muss sich sehr, sehr stark konzentrieren, um Sie zu verstehen.
Ich verstehe.
Ich muss gerade überlegen, woran das liegt.
Ich kann das gar nicht so auf den Punkt bringen.
Es ist mir nur aufgefallen, dass ich Sie tatsächlich nicht so gut verstehen kann.
Und Sie machen viele, viele kleine Fehler.
Das sind keine schlimmen Sachen.
Aber da fehlt zum Beispiel ein Artikel oder ...
Deklination oder Wertposition.
Ja, Wertposition.
Das sind so Winzigkeiten.
Das ist jetzt nichts, was den Sinn entstellt und was verhindert, dass man weiß, wovon Sie sprechen.
Aber so ein kleiner Schönheitsfehler, sage ich mal, ist es.
Und was mir aufgefallen ist, und ich glaube, da sind die Düsseldorfer ziemlich kritisch.
Sie haben relativ wenig Fachbegriffe verwendet.
Sie haben zum Beispiel in Familienanalyse gibt es an, dass der Vater einen Myokadenfakt hatte.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Und was war noch?
Ein Brustkrebs.
Ja, die Schwester leidet an Mamakarsinolen.
Das haben Sie ein bisschen sehr schematisch gemacht.
Da ist vielleicht noch so ein kleiner Verbindungsatz.
Wäre vielleicht nett.
Sie haben dann immer gesagt, Myoksenanalyse ergibt das und das.
Sozialanalyse ergibt das und das.
Familienanalyse ergibt das und das.
Ja, da kann man vielleicht auch mal so ein bisschen was anderes formulieren, dass man eben sagt,
auf die Frage nach der Familienanalyse gab die Patientin an das und das.
Sie können das.
Sie können ganz gute Hauptanalyse formulieren.
Das habe ich gehört. Sie machen das eigentlich sehr, sehr gut.
Danke.
Und es sind wirklich nur so Winzigkeiten, dass das mit einmal was fehlt.
Und so fehlt auch wieder irgendwas.
Ich habe es nicht auf einen Punkt mitschreiben können.
Sie stellte sich mit was auch immer bei uns vor oder wegen bei uns vor.
Aber irgendwas fehlte da drin in dem Satz.
Man müsste tatsächlich auch mal reinhorchen an der richtigen Stelle, um den Fehler zu finden.
Aber irgendwie war der Satz nicht ganz vollständig.
Schreiben Sie den Satz noch einmal für sich tatsächlich grammatikalisch richtig aus.
Ja.
Und dass er vollständig ist.
Und prägen Sie sich den ein, dass Sie den auf alle Fälle, diese allererste Hürde, da steht und fällt so viel damit.
Ja.
Was mir sehr positiv aufgefallen ist, war schon ein bisschen doll viel.
Sie haben immer wieder die Patienten mit Namen angesprochen.
Ja, das ist also sehr nett.
Und Sie haben mich auch angeguckt.
Und das fand ich eigentlich auch sehr schön.
Danke schön.
Und Sie haben auch reagiert auf das, was die Patientin Ihnen schon erzählt hat.
Sie haben da gesagt, ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass eine Winzigkeit haben Sie nicht ganz richtig verstanden.
Das war das mit dem Abendessen, dass ich gesagt habe, die Schmerzen fingen nach dem Abendessen an.
Dann haben Sie ja gesagt, hat sonst noch jemand in der Familie?
Dann habe ich ja gesagt, nee, ich bin die Einzige, die was hat.
Und da haben Sie draus verstanden, ich war die Einzige, die gegessen hat.
Nee, also wir haben schon als Familie gegessen, aber ich bin die Einzige, die die Beschwerden hat.
Gut, lass mal gucken, was ich hier noch finde.
Sonst ist mir glaube ich, ja, auch so eine witzige, ja, eine süße Sache, eine herzliche Ursache, haben Sie ausgeschlossen.
Ja, da habe ich ja nachgehackt.
Also eine herzbedingte Ursache.
Herzbedingte.
Herzliche Grüße oder herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag, ja, oder herzlichen Dank, ja, aber herzbedingt oder ja, gut.
Aber das ist sehr charmant, sage ich jetzt mal.
Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist, das ist so eine typische Winzigkeit.
Als differenzial diagnostisch kommt das und das in Frage.
Entweder als Differenzialdiagnose, ja, dann ist es ein Nomen oder differenzial diagnostisch kommt auch das und das in Frage.
Wobei, da fand ich eigentlich auch spannend, dass Sie, dass Sie die Tugendigatur erwähnt haben, interessant.
Tugendiguration oder was man das nennt.
Also ein tatsächlich gynäkologisches Thema fand ich und auch Nephrolithiasis haben Sie auch erwähnt.
Und ja, also das Augenblick.
Sonst habe ich eigentlich nichts gefunden.
Sie waren schneller mit den Zeichen, als ich das verstehen konnte.
Aber da unterstelle ich jetzt einfach mal, dass Sie das richtig gesagt haben.
Wie gesagt, ein bisschen Verständigungsprobleme habe ich mit Ihnen.
Ich musste sehr gut zuhören.
Vielleicht wäre es hilfreich, wenn Sie ein bisschen Tempo rausnehmen.
Sie sprechen ganz schön schnell.
Wie gesagt, Sie machen ziemlich gute und vollständige Satzkonstruktionen.
So mit Haupt- und Nebensatz, das gefällt mir immer gut.
Aber wie gesagt, da schleichen sich da so Winzigkeiten ein.
Aber ich denke, nichts, was unerträglich ist.
Auch einen Blick, ich muss überlegen.
Ja, vielleicht noch eine Sache.
Die Patientin hat eine Nebenerkrankung angegeben.
Sie haben sich dann mit der Hypotheriose eigentlich zufriedengestellt und haben nicht weitergeholt.
Aber es gibt weitere.
Sie hätte noch eine chronische Bronchitis Auflage gehabt.
Ja, aber okay, gut.
Natürlich bei dieser so eingängigen und auf der Hand liegenden Diagnose.
Sie liegen natürlich richtig mit der Appendizit, das ist ja völlig klar.
Da müssen Sie aber auch damit rechnen, dass die Prüfer Sie noch auf irgendwelche Nebenschienen festnageln.
Dass die zum Beispiel fragen nach dem Myokadinfarkt beim Vater.
Oder dass die fragen nach dem Mamakad-Synom bei der Schwester.
Da geben die sicher wahrscheinlich nicht mit einer Erkrankung.
Oder sie fragen vielleicht nach der Schilddrüsenerkrankung und fragen da nach typischen Symptomen oder so.
Mit sowas muss man rechnen, wenn man meint, man hat so einen einfachen Fall,
wo die Diagnose sich eigentlich so anbahnt schon in den ersten drei Sätzen der Patientin oder des Patienten.
Da kann Ihnen das passieren, dass die Prüfer dann auf einer ganz unerwarteten Schiene irgendwo noch nachbohren.
Also eigentlich meine Empfehlung für Sie, ein bisschen Tempo rausnehmen.
Und vielleicht noch, dass Sie sich mehr aneignen, dass Sie tatsächlich in dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch die Fachbegriffe verwenden.
Und meine Empfehlung ist ja immer, nicht gegenüber den Patienten schon die Diagnose zu äußern.
Das mögen andere Kollegen vielleicht anders sehen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, es gibt vielleicht Erfahrungswerte, was andere, die die Prüfung hinter sich haben, erlebt haben.
Oder auch was so unter Kollegen üblich ist.
Ich denke immer, es ist gescheiter zu sagen, ich habe zwar einen Verdacht, der geht in eine Richtung.
Ich muss das aber noch überprüfen.
Und wir schauen erstmal genau die Befunde ab und die Ergebnisse der Untersuchung.
Und dann sage ich Ihnen, was Sie vermutlich haben und wie wir dagegen vorgehen können, was wir für Maßnahmen angehen.
Und ja, gut. Ja, ich denke, damit können wir heute Nacht alle gut schlafen.